around four and a half million years ago
a river began flowing across the
Colorado Plateau carving the Grand
Canyon scientists are divided on how the
river came into existence they have two
conflicting scenarios the river either
worked its way across the plateau from
Southwest to Northeast by headward
erosion or the other way around by
spillover for scientists to apply the
spillover theory to the Grand Canyon
they have to find a lake and it is
likely to be in the East where the
elevation is higher today there is no
lake but there are two hundred feet of
green layered deposits remnants of an
ancient lake called Lake video Qi and so
this green layer right here reflects the
idea that Lake viduh Ho Chi was in
existence east of the Grand Canyon
between sixteen and six million years
ago over ten million years a lake
deposited fine-grained sediments like
silt clay and sand mixed with grey
volcanic ash the deposits indicate the
existence of a lake but they don't show
how the lake over spilled and carved the
canyon
John Douglas geography professor at
Paradise Valley Community College in
Arizona wanted an effective way to test
the theory he built a small scale model
of the Grand Canyon to demonstrate how
the lake could have overflowed
six million years ago the canyon wasn't
yet carved but Lake bit of Ho Chi was
full to the point of overflow and then
as a lake came in the lake filled it
filled and filled higher and iron higher
until eventually spilled across the
lowest point across the Kaibab plateau
and then water poured down the other
side those waterfalls continued to
retreat back and the whole time you're
cutting Grand Canyon Douglass suggests
that Lake Buddha Ho Chi drained and
formed a stream a steep gradient of the
riverbed caused the stream to cut deep
into the rock over time the size of the
stream increased and more and more water
poured out of the lake which in turn cut
deeper and deeper into the rock
but not all geologists agree they say
there is no evidence of their ever being
a lake large enough to carve the Grand
Canyon so at present there is still no
definitive answer as to how the river
came into existence
what we do know is that when it began
flowing around four and a half million
years ago it cut a one-mile deep scar in
the surface